(mumbling)
- Awesome.
- Are you ready?
- Alrighty, let's do this.
- You have a little...
- Thank you.
- And also.
- Oh. (laughs)
Oink oink!
- Yeah.
- Thanks!
- How are you?
- Good, tired.
Yeah, the baby had a
rough night last night,
but you know, that's how it goes.
- I don't know how you do it.
- You just do.
(dramatic music)
Honey!
- Yeah.
- There's no school today.
- It's Monday.
- I know! What are we gonna do?
- How much we paying this place?
- Where are we going?
- To work, you're coming with mama today.
- Yay.
- If I was a mom, I'd probably
be a stay at home mom.
My mom was a stay at home mom.
- So just wanted to
check in with everyone,
and see where we're all at.
- Sorry, excuse me.
Hey babe, what's up?
- I'm sorry I'm trying here,
but she needs the Pichu Jiju song.
- No I can't.
- She really misses you.
- Okay,
♫ Pichu jiju I love you, yes I do ♫
(hissing)
I'm in here, I'm pumping!
Don't come in! Don't come in!
- Uh.
- Get out of here!
♫ I love you, Pich-- ♫
- Oh, we're all going salsa dancing,
and grabbing drinks after
work, you wanna come?
- Sounds like fun, but I gotta get home.
- Uh, okay.
- Maybe next time?
- Yeah.
- Thanks for the invite!
- Of course.
(cheerful music)